my producer James sent me this article
today
that is really disturbing it's in The
Wall Street Journal dealerships give car
buyers advice stop paying your loan and
just buy a car and repo your current car
now that's such a dumb idea that I can't
believe that people are actually doing
it but they are apparently the trade-in
is where the bike this is from the Wall
Street Journal where a buyer hands a car
back to the dealership and uses it as
credit towards another one is often a
crucial step in car buying but some
dealerships are instead telling buyers
to give their old cars back to the
lender a voluntary repossession and then
sell them a new car in a practice known
as kicking the trade I've never heard
that phrase kicking the trade it's
difficult to estimate how much how often
this happens auto sales veterans say the
practice is an open secret in some
showrooms broadly vehicles are getting
more expensive and Americans are
struggling to afford them dealerships
now make more money arranging financing
than selling vehicles which has been
true for 25 years if the car loan goes
bad it typically isn't the dealership
that's on the hook it is the borrower
and the lender consumer lawyers say they
have seen more of such cases five years
ago it happened two or three times a
year
says Daniel Blin a Connecticut based
attorney who has sued dealerships and
auto dealers now we're hearing about it
once a month not twice a year problems
often begin when the consumers who buy
cars they can't afford or sign loans
they don't understand dealerships
compound the trouble so here's the deal
in other words these unethical
dealerships are suggesting to someone
well we really don't want to take your
trade-in just quit paying the payments
on it call your lender and tell them to
come get it
that's a repossession it's a voluntary
repossession now if they don't want take
your trade-in it's because you're
upside-down the car meaning you owe more
on it than it's worth
okay so you owe $22,000 on a car that's
worth 17 your $5,000 in the hole
that would be a normal transaction and
this unethical dealership suggest to you
that instead of covering the $5,000 the
$22,000 that you owe or the $5,000 that
you're short were you to trade it in or
sell it instead of doing that just don't
pay the payments any more and get repo'd
well obviously there's a moral component
you didn't you signed a piece of paper
that said you were gonna pay car
payments and you didn't pay them that's
a moral component there's a legal
component you're gonna get your butt
sued there's a credit component and that
is you've destroyed your credit of
course they sell you a car before the
repo actually occurs and before your
credit drops and so this is someone
often times that could be current on
their car and instead of just working a
traditional trade-in maybe going further
in the hole which would be a bad deal
too but instead of doing that they do a
voluntary repossession well let me tell
you what happens when you owe twenty two
thousand dollars on a car worth 17 and
you get it repo'd
they don't sell the car for 17 you can't
get retail or private sale for a car at
a repo lot they auction it a repo
auction so what is the $17,000 car bring
it a repo auction hmm
8 or 10 thousand bucks okay so instead
of now owing $5,000 difference when they
come after you for the difference
because they will sue you for the
deficit the deficit is now twelve
fourteen thousand bucks instead of five
thousand bucks and you destroyed your
credit also you could get another car
Wow
really stupid on your part unbelievably
crooked unethical horrible get sued for
it by the dealerships so this is what
happens when things get out of control
of course anytime someone's writing an
article police like the Wall Street
Journal if say well cars are so
expensive people can't afford them not
really new cars are so expensive that
you can't afford them if you're a broke
person which has always been the case by
the way
broke people have never been able to
afford things there broke people when I
was broke people I couldn't afford a new
car I've been broke people I know what
broke people looks like you can't afford
a dadgum car what's happened in the u.s.
is not the cars have gone up so much the
people can't afford a nice car what's
happened is is that we've raised a whole
generation or three of children who
refuse to grow up and refuse to tell
themselves no and so they go buy cars
they can't afford and then when I want
another car and someone says I still
can't afford it and in a matter of fact
I don't even want your trade-in we think
me an AE and you throw a fit like a
little baby child on the cereal aisle
who spoiled rotten and can't get a box
of cereal like you're freaking four
years old you're red-faced and you have
your little fists balled up and you
stomp your little foot now I'm entitled
to a new car because I breathe air and
I'm an American you're not entitled to
nothing you're broke you're entitled
what you've saved up the money and got
the money for that's all you're entitled
to driving a new car is not a human
right that's dumber than crap and people
act like it is you know Americans just
can't afford a new car Americans there's
never been a before a new car except the
ones that had money and all we've done
is financed people into stuff that they
can't afford the average car payment
America right now according to Experian
is 554 dollars over 84 months that's the
average car payment in America today
which some of you were sitting on 700
our car payments you feel right superior
right now no you ought to feel smart
dumb more stupid than the 554 if you
think you're superior because you got
354 no you're still stupid you've a car
payment get rid of the car payment pay
cash for things that way you'll have
some money
is really not rocket science you guys
don't let some crooked dealership talk
you into voluntary repo oh my goodness